hey everyone it's sarah with
registerednessrn.com and in this video
i'm going to demonstrate how to recap a
needle using the one hand
scoop technique now you want to avoid
recapping needles
due to the high risk of needle stick
injuries
however sometimes as a nurse you have to
recap a needle
and to do this safely you want to use a
technique that decreases the risk of a
needle stick
when recapping a needle you want to
avoid using this technique as it carries
a much greater risk for a needle stick
injury therefore it is recommended that
when you
do have to recap a needle that you use
the one hand scoop technique
so i have a situation where i need to
recap this needle
because i have used this needle to
withdraw medication from a vial
and i need to remove this needle and
apply a new one
so i can administer it to the patient so
i have kept the original cap and
packaging to help assist me do this
so what i'm going to do is
i'm going to use just one hand hence why
we call it the one
hand scoop technique i'm going to keep
my non-dominant hand by my side so i'm
only going to have my dominant hand
holding the barrel of the syringe and
then carefully
i'm going to place the needle
inside of the cap until i can no longer
get it inside the cap
then i'm going to lift up like this
and then take that one hand that i
wasn't using and just snap the cap on
alternatively when using the one hand
scoop technique
some protocols require that you use a
hard surface to snap the cap into place
without using the other hand then i'm
going to remove and dispose of the
needle per my facilities protocol
okay so that wraps up this demonstration
on how to recap a needle using the one
hand scoop technique
and if you'd like to watch some other
nursing skill videos you can access the
link in the youtube description below